حقيقه نحن نتحدث عن اعداد كبيره من الناس
ليس فقط المنكوبين بسبب الزلزال الذين
هدمت بيوتهم بسبب الزلزال هم يحتاجون فقط
الى المساعده هناك يعني الاف الاشخاص
الذين خرجوا من منازلهم لا يريدون العوده
الى منازلهم تخوفا من ضربات الزلازل التي
هزت هذه المنطقه خلال الايام الماضيه هذه
احدى الحدائق المهمه والكبيره في مدينه
غازي عنتاب وقد يعني تحولت الى مخيم بعد
ان جلس
الاهالي في هذه الحديقه بدون خيام وقاموا
باشعال النيران ثم هناك اشخاص كان لديهم
بعض السيارات يجلسون بداخلها لكن بعد يعني
بعد ايام بعد يومين تقريبا من هذه من هذا
الوضع بدات عمليه نصب القيام هي لا تكفي
لجميع الاشخاص الموجودين بالقرب من هنا
يوجد مركزي وهذا المخيم يمكن ان يعني ناخذ
صوره مباشره من هذا المخيم الذي يعني يوجد
فيه عدد لا باس به من الخيام وقد يعني
بدات العوائل بالدخول لهذه القيام لكن نحن
نتحدث عن حاله عاجله وطاريه لذلك هذه
الخيام ليست دافئه من الداخل ليس جميعها
دافئه بحاجه الى بعض الحاجات الاساسيه
الخاصه بالتدفئه لان درجات الحراره متدنيه
نحن نتحدث عن حديقه كانت من اهم الحدائق
واكبرها في مدينه يعني غازي عنتاب والان
يعني تحولت الى مخيم بهذا الشكل كما
تشاهدون هذه الصور المباشره هذه مثلا كانت
احدى
المناطق الخاصه بالعالم الاطفال نشاهد هنا
هؤلاء قضوا ليلتهم في البرد في هذه في هذا
المخيم يحاولون هنا يعني
اللعب في
في هذه الالعاب هنا اشعال للنيران في
محاوله للتدفئه طبعا اشعار لا يتوقف طوارئ
الليل حتى في النهار لان درجات الحراره
منخفضه
ايضا نحن نشاهد هنا
هذه الخيام التي يعني
باتت مسكنا جديدا لاهالي غازي عنتاب طبعا
هناك عده نقاط تتجمع فيها هذه الخيام ليس
فقط في هذه الحديقه هنالك حدائق اخرى
هنالك ساحات عامه جميعها يتم بناؤها بشكل
يكون بعيد عن الابنيه السكنيه لو نلاحظ
مثلا هذه الخيام هنا من خلفنا يوجد بناء
هناك مسافه بين هذا البناء وهذه الخيام
بحيث لو ان لا سمح الله لو جاءت هزه ارضيه
او ارتداده وتضرر هذا البناء لا ياتي
بالضرر على هذه الخيام هم يحاولون ان
يكونوا في مناطق مفتوحه في مناطق بعيده عن
عن الابنيه حتى لو تكررت هذه الزلازل
القويه ان لا يتاذوا هنا محاوله الجميع
يحاول اشعار النيران يحاولون يعني
ان يحصلوا على مصادر للدفء وايضا يحاولون
ان يتاقلموا مع الظرف الحالي لان الوضع لا
يبدو انه سينتهي قريبا كما نشاهد يعني هذه
الصور المباشره من مدينه غازي عنتاب من
وسط مدينه غازي عنتاب نشاهد هنا
هذا هو حال الاهالي الصوره تنقل
حالهم وتنقل الواقع الذي يعيشوه بعد هذا
الزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه ايضا كما ذكرت
شعل النيران هي احد الطرق الرئيسيه
والاساسيه في محاوله الحصول على تدفئه
يعني في ظل درجات الحراره المتدنيه التي
يعني وصلت الى معدون الصفر نشاهد هنا ايضا
محاولات يعني الجميع يحاولون اشعار
النيران
ويحاولون الحصول على الدفئ بقدر الامكان
طبعا هنالك
صباحا قبل قليل لان راينا سيارات قامت به
توزيع الخبز على الاهالي هنا وقاموا
بتوزيع المياه ايضا هي محاولات من منظمات
يعني متعدده بما فيها بلديه غازي عنتاب
المسؤوله عن يعني تقديم الدعم بالاضافه
الى افاد تقديم الدعم لهؤلاء الذين اصبحوا
يعني نازحين او الفارين من هذه الزلازل
فريم المنازلهم يحاولون تقديم بعض الامور
الاساسيه حتى يعني يخفف عنهم من وطات هذه
الحياه التي بدات يعني بداوا يتاقلمون
عليها الحياه الجديده يمكننا العوده
نعم مريم يعني هذا هو جانب من القيام جانب
من الوضع الذي يعني تعيشه مدينه غازي
عنتاب شكرا جزيلا لك منتصر ابو نبوت من
امام هذا المخيم
للمنكوبين من الزلزال في غازي عنتاب شكرا
جزيلا لك